monsieur le président
ce président de la commission des lois
madame la rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
Sénat est examine aujourd'hui la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
visant à protéger et à garantir le droit
fondamental à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse dans sa version adoptée en
première lecture par l'Assemblée
nationale le 24 novembre dernier
ce texte
n'est pas encore abouti
le rapport de la commission des Lois du
Sénat ne manque d'ailleurs pas de le
relever
mais il est le fruit d'un travail
constructif et transpartisans
entre les nombreux groupes politiques de
la chambre basse et je veux ici
d'ailleurs saluer les présidentes
bergers et panneaux
depuis l'arrêt rendu le 24 juin 2022 par
la Cour suprême des États-Unis
six propositions de loi
constitutionnelle ont été déposés sur
les bureaux des assemblées
6 propositions
y vision différente
et de beaux débats passés
présent
et à venir devant vos deux assemblées
l'importance des initiatives
parlementaires
dans cette matière démontre que le
revirement de jurisprudence de la Cour
suprême des États-Unis a eu l'effet chez
nous d'un électrochoc
nous devons être vigilants à ce que la
solidité de nos institutions se
maintiennent à l'épreuve du temps et que
ce droit
soit préservé
et quel droit
ce droit chermon conquis que chaque
femme a disposé de son corps
disons-le en la matière nous ne partons
pas de rien
et il ne faut pas mésestimer l'oeuvre du
Conseil constitutionnel
celui-ci depuis sa décision du 27 juin
reconnaître en effet que le droit à
l'IVG résulte de la liberté de la femme
qui découle de l'article 2 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen
mais il s'agite à présent d'aller plus
loin
et de conférer un fondement
constitutionnel autonome à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
en l'érigeant explicitement au-delà de
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel en liberté fondamentale
pour toutes ces raisons je persiste et
je signe le Gouvernement soutiendra
toutes les initiatives parlementaires
qui viseraient à constitutionnaliser le
droit à l'IVG
à ceux qui opposent à cette initiative
par le montant que le droit à
l'avortement n'est pas menacé en France
je réponds simplement ceci
n'attendons pas qu'il soit trop tard
pour le défendre le droit des femmes
disposer de leur corps
doit être inaliénable
en 1975
Simone Veil expliquait que l'objectif du
gouvernement était de créer je la cite
une loi réellement applicable
dissuasive
protectrice le législateur à travers de
nombreux textes successifs a atteint ses
objectifs mais l'objectif que nous
poursuivons aujourd'hui est autre il
s'agite à présent de protéger ce droit
en l'élevant au plus haut rang de la
hiérarchie des normes notre Constitution
ce faisant nous donnerions avoir à
toutes les femmes toutes les femmes
qu'elles ont le choix
que celui-ci leur appartient et qu'elles
sont soutenues par la société tout
entière dans ce choix car oui les
exemples étrangers partout dans le monde
nous le démontre une démocratie digne de
ce nom ne peut exister sans l'émacie
sans l'émancipation totale de la moitié
de sa population
je tire votre attention sur la nécessité
de ne pas se tromper de débat
j'entends évidemment la commission des
lois lorsqu'elle pointe qu'une telle
inscription ne résoudrait pas les
difficultés concrètes d'accès à l'IVG
qui peuvent se rencontrer sur le terrain
le gouvernement est notamment mes
collègues Braun et Rome le gouvernement
disait j'ai pleinement engagé pour
rendre ce droit le plus effectif
concrètement sur le terrain mais il
s'agit là en réalité de deux sujets
différents
l'effectivité d'un droit d'une part et
sa protection juridique d'autre part si
les modalités d'exercice du droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
doivent pouvoir continuer à être
encadrés par le législateur car il
s'agit du niveau normatif le plus adapté
pour le faire le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse lui-même ne doit
pas être entravée
ou pire aboli or une garantie
constitutionnelle peut nous assurer pour
l'avenir
et ce pour une raison
notamment que j'avais évoqué devant vous
en octobre dernier
constitutionnaliser le droit à l'IVG
c'est s'assurer que ceux qui auraient se
néfaste projet ne puisse le faire sans
l'accord du Sénat oui inscrire le droit
à l'IVG dans la Constitution c'est
garantir que le Sénat aura le dernier
mot pour protéger ce droit
comme il en a déjà protégé tant d'autres
dans la noble mission qui est la sienne
vous l'aurez compris tout comme la
commission gouvernement n'a pas changé
d'avis il est lui favorable à
l'inscription du droit à l'IVG dans
notre Constitution monsieur le président
monsieur le garde des sceaux monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame l'a rapporteur permettez-moi tout
d'abord de saluer l'extrême
pertinence et la vigueur de la
présentation du rapport par Madame Agnès
canaillé elle justifie amplement notre
refus
de voter cette proposition de loi je
reprendrai seulement quelques-uns des
arguments qu'elle a énoncé en
m'attachant au texte de cette
proposition
je ne m'attarderai pas sur le fait
qu'elle n'est pas rédigée en français
j'ai cru constater que ça n'était qu'un
détail et qu'on peut faire des fautes de
grammaire dans la Constitution sans que
personne ne s'en est meuf en revanche en
revanche
je veux dire que
cette rédaction ne définit pas ce qu'est
le droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse le présente comme un absolu
une sorte de créance sur la société et
ne prévoit de garantie par le
législateur que pour l'effectivité qui
relève plutôt de l'organisation du
système de santé et pour les galaxies
qui est naturellement une mesure sociale
tout à fait estimable mais qui n'est pas
au cœur du débat
ce qui est au cœur du débat en revanche
c'est la substance de ce droit
indéfini à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse que les auteurs de cette
proposition prétendent de voir
reconnaître comme le garde des sceaux la
suggérer dans son intervention
l'idée que ce droit serait illimité et
le mettrait à part de toutes les autres
libertés constitutionnelles n'est pas
exclu par la rédaction qui a été adopté
et il me semble que on ne peut
reconnaître un droit à une liberté sans
en prévoir aussi les conditions
c'est-à-dire les limites et c'est ce qui
fait précisément l'équilibre de la loi
veille
jusqu'à l'achèvement d'un certain délai
c'est la liberté de la femme qui prévaut
après l'achèvement de ce délai c'est la
protection de l'enfant à naître dont je
m'étonne que personne n'est parlé et
bien cet équilibre fondamental c'est
celui qui précisément a fait accepter la
loi veille par la société française
depuis près de 50 ans et qui justifie
aujourd'hui qu'il y ait une forme de
consensus autour du droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
tel qu'il a été défini par la loi veille
même si elle a évolué au cours du temps
par un certain nombre de réforme alors
la question qui se pose à nous c'est
est-ce que il est pertinent d'inscrire
une liberté ou un droit dans la
Constitution je réponds que c'est déjà
le cas l'article premier prévoit
l'égalité devant la loi l'article
premier prévoit le respect de toutes les
croyances on y a ajouté les libertés
locales avec l'organisation
décentralisée de la République les
galaxies des femmes et des hommes aux
fonctions électives on a décidé aussi
que nul ne peut être condamné à la peine
de mort c'est donc bien un lieu qui
permet d'accueillir des libertés que le
pouvoir constituant qui est souverain
est auquel on peut assigner aucune
limite veut voir consacrer
je propose une contre proposition au
texte qui nous est soumis et cette
contre proposition elle vise à garantir
l'équilibre de la loi vers elle reprend
l'énoncé d'une liberté qui a été
reconnue par le Conseil constitutionnel
dans sa décision du 27 juin 2001 et elle
consolide cette liberté mais elle
prévoit aussi que le législateur en
détermine les conditions et donc les
limites comme la prévue la loi vert et
je crois qu'on ne peut pas sortir de
cette équation il n'y a pas de droit
absolu il y a une liberté déjà reconnue
et que nous pouvons écrire dans la
Constitution mais à la condition qu'il y
ait une conciliation entre les droits de
la femme enceinte de mettre fin à sa
grossesse et la protection de l'enfant à
naître après un certain délai voilà
monsieur le Président ce que je voulais
vous dire monsieur le garde des sceaux
vous avez dit tout à l'heure rappelons
une formule célèbre qu'il ne fallait
toucher à la constitution que d'une main
tremblante les vôtres sont restés dans
vos poches
[Applaudissements]
et il me semble qu'on aurait tout de
même intérêt puisque vous critiquez un
certain nombre de rédaction avoir celles
que le gouvernement pourrait nous
soumettre après à vie du Conseil d'État
pour engager un processus qui aurait de
meilleures chances d'aboutir vous restez
sur le banc de touche libre à vous c'est
un confort que nous ne voulons pas vous
donner durablement car le verrou du
Sénat peut être levé et vous serez alors
mis face à vos responsabilités
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Colette mélo pour le
groupe les indépendants pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues le texte que nous examinons a
été adopté à l'Assemblée nationale à une
très large majorité il vise à faire de
l'IVG un droit constitutionnel sa
rédaction était initialement
identique à celle du texte rejetée par
notre chambre en octobre dernier elle a
été modifiée par les députés lors de son
examen en séance publique pour favoriser
son adoption notre groupe considère que
toute femme doit avoir la possibilité
d'interrompre sa grossesse lorsqu'elle
le décide dans le cadre du régime établi
par la loi ce régime comme bien d'autres
et le fruit de l'équilibre délicat entre
la liberté de la mer d'une part et la
sauvegarde de la dignité de la personne
humaine d'autre part certaines
évolutions législatives étrangères font
craindre on recule des libertés un
revirement de jurisprudence de la Cour
suprême américaine
ainsi rendu aux Etats le droit
d'interdire ou d'autoriser
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
il s'agit d'un retour en arrière
manifeste plus proche de nous
législation a été durci en Pologne et en
Hongrie réduisant fortement l'accès à
l'IVG il reste d'ailleurs interdit à
Malte les reculs de cette liberté se
traduisent par des poursuites pénales
tant pour la mère que pour le médecin
comme nos concitoyens ces évolutions
nous inquiète dans notre pays
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
n'est pas aujourd'hui menacée
politiquement les délais ont ainsi
récemment été allongés de 12 à 14
semaines aucun parti politique de l'arc
républicain ne plaide pour la remise en
cause de l'IVG
cependant ce qui menace l'IVG c'est bien
davantage le manque de moyens le manque
de médecins qui transforme cette
intervention en parcours de la
combattante le
Gour verte à la constitutionnalisation
de l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse si cette proposition venait à
être votée en terminantique il faudrait
encore la soumettre à un référendum pour
que la Constitution soit modifiée nous
avons cru comprendre qu'il y a quelques
réticences à mener un tel référendum y
compris d'ailleurs parmi les auteurs de
la proposition de loi dans ces
conditions il sera difficile d'expliquer
pourquoi l'Assemblée nationale et le
Sénat ont débattu longuement et à
plusieurs reprises d'une
constitutionnalisation tant que ces
débats sans que c'est débats n'étant
rien amélioré l'accès de nos
concitoyennes à l'IVG nous l'avons dit
notre groupe est très attaché aux
libertés individuelles et notamment à
celle d'interrompre une grossesse nous
souhaitons également que nos
concitoyennes bénéficient d'avancer
concrète à cet égard il nous semble
nécessaire de densifier l'offre de soins
sur notre territoire la problématique
des médicaux et bien connu de notre
assemblée elle a de graves conséquences
et notamment en matière d'IVG il
conviendrait également d’améliorer
l'accompagnement des femmes décidant
d'avorter tout au long de leur parcours
notamment quant à la gestion des délais
trop de femmes sont encore contraintes
de se rendre à l'étranger pour avorter
que ces femmes soient mineures ou non
quels étaient victimes d'agressions ou
non l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse est toujours une épreuve il
est de notre devoir d'accompagner au
mieux les femmes qui ont recours les
membres de notre groupe Les Indépendants
Républiques et territoires sont
unanimement favorables à la liberté
d'avorter certains s'interrogent sur
l'intérêt de son inscription dans la
Constitution chacun votera donc selon
ses convictions en ce qui me concerne je
ne prendrai pas par au vote car les
termes de la loi veillent me paraissent
suffisamment équilibrée
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Mélanie Vogel pour le
groupe écologiste pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues donc nous
prononçons aujourd'hui encore sur
l'introduction du droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution je souhaitais d'abord
saluer le travail de l'Assemblée
nationale ce vote qui a rendu si fière
les Françaises et les Français et le
sens de l'intérêt général qui a été
celui de Mathilde panot d'Aurore berger
et de toutes celles et ceux qui à gauche
comme à droite on suit se rassembler
autour d'un impératif bien plus grand
que nos désaccords politiques la loi
veille que tant d'évoquer ici et
évoqueront je suis sûr aujourd'hui la
loi Veil est donc le point de départ de
l'accès des phases au droit à
l'avortement en France a nécessité comme
tant d'autres victoires politiques la
réunion de trois éléments la
mobilisation des féministes d'abord et
comme toujours des féministes qui des
années durant et depuis des décennies
ont battu le pavé mais leur vie en
danger pour sauver tant d'autres de
l'horreur et pour imposer la
reconnaissance du dieu le plus
fondamental celui que nous avons à
disposer de nos à contrôler notre
fécondité et plus largement à maîtriser
nos vies
la détermination et la responsabilité de
la gauche ensuite d'une gauche qui a su
à un moment donné de l'histoire et quand
bien même la loi veille était loin bien
loin de notre idéal rendre l'imparfait
mais nécessaire victoire possible et
enfin et c'est de cela et profondément
de cela au fond dont il est question
aujourd'hui de la dignité d'une partie
de la droite une certaine partie de la
droite qui en dépit des pressions du
conservatisme de l'idéologie violemment
sexiste et misogyne qui pétrissait alors
une bonne partie de ses rangs c'est
allié à un combat dont aucune digne
représentant de la nation ne pouvait
persister à freiner l'aboutissement nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une situation
foncièrement similaire parce qu'elle est
tant attachée à ce qui constitue l'une
des conditions les plus fondamentales de
les galaxies à la citoyenneté 86% de la
population française souhaite voir le
droit à l'IVG entrer dans la
Constitution dans ces 86%, se trouvent
tant de vos filles de vos petites filles
et de leurs amis tous celles et ceux qui
savent dans leur cher qui n'est jamais
quand il est question d'IVG de
protection superflue et qu'il vaut
toujours mieux trembler d'une main pour
protéger des droits que se tétanisé pour
refuser de le faire pas pour le symbole
ni pour l'esthétique mais par la
responsabilité immense que nous confère
la conscience aiguë que nous avons des
menaces qui planent toujours sur les
droits des femmes et de la force de ce
message d'espérance que la France peut
aujourd'hui envoyer au monde entier car
si la France n'est pas un pays magique
protégé de la marge du monde immunisée
contre les reculs elle est aujourd'hui
un pays tout particulier un pays que pas
seulement les américaines mais les
Polonaises les maltaises les Hongroises
les Allemandes les Italiens les
Iraniennes les chiliennes regardent
parce que ce pays peut aujourd'hui dans
cette période si sombre pour les droits
des femmes tracés enfin un chemin
d'espoir et de progrès je ne sais pas
chers collègues
combien d'entre vous aujourd'hui
choisiront quel camp mais je sais
profondément une chose comme je crois
intimement beaucoup ici le savent ceux
qui voteront aujourd'hui en faveur de
l'inscription du droit à l'avortement
dans la Constitution n'auront jamais
jamais honte de leur vote notamment
quand viendra le jour où le Conseil
constitutionnel
censura une loi attaquant le droit à
l'IVG et que les autres
auront tout le mal du monde à expliquer
à leur petite fille qu'ils auront tout
fait pour œuvrer à les protéger en ce
qui nous concerne parce que dans les
moments de bascule de l'histoire nous
serons toujours à notre responsabilité
nous sommes prêtes et prêts à voter un
texte qui même s'il venait à l'issue du
débat à ne pas pleinement nous
satisfaire permettrait de poursuivre
l'avancée de notre pays vers cette
grande victoire protéger un droit avant
qu'il soit menacé évidemment quand ils
le sera il sera trop tard pour agir je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Xavier yakovelli
pour le groupe RDPI pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le garder
ce mes chers collègues le 19 octobre
dernier le Sénat rejetait la proposition
de loi constitutionnelle de notre
collègue Mélanie Vogel visant à protéger
et à garantir le droit fondamental à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et à la contraception outre les
arguments avancés lors de ces débats je
ne reviendrai pas dessus nous
retiendrons que ce vote fut le signal
malheureux envoyé à nos concitoyens et
particulièrement aux femmes
ne soyons pas aveugle de leur demande
ils nous regardent aujourd'hui le droit
à l'IVG est remis en cause dans le monde
c'est un fait depuis l'animation de la
raie Roanne versus wad très État
américain ont rendu illégal l'avortement
et 5 en ont limité l'accès et cela en
moins d'un an au sein même de l'Union
européenne les menaces qui pèsent sur ce
droit sont visibles je prends l'exemple
pris tout à l'heure par le garde des
sceaux sur la Hongrie où on oblige
maintenant les femmes avant d'avorter à
écouter le cœur du fœtus
il est donc légitime de s'interroger sur
son avenir en France à l'image de la
Marche pour la vie du 22 janvier dernier
ou encore le récent colloque anti IVG
parrainé par notre collègue malheureux
sénateur ravier les militants
anti-avortement constituent et
continuent d'utiliser tous les moyens
possibles pour diffuser leur idéologie
rétrograde et pernicieuse vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le garder sceau un
droit n'est jamais acquis l'histoire
nous le prouve et je pourrais ajouter
que ce n'est encore moins qui lorsque
c'est un droit pour les femmes ou un
droit pour les enfants
et malgré cela on dépile des solides
arguments avancés nous n'avons pas
réussi à obtenir une majorité en
première lecture pour protéger et
garantir le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse en inscrivant
dans notre Constitution qu'avons-nous
qu'attendons-nous mes chers collègues
pour le faire nous nous trompons pas de
débat il ne s'agit pas ici d'empêcher un
retour en arrière qui suscite la crainte
d'abandon de nos concitoyens nous avons
de nouveau l'occasion de voter en ce
sens saisissons là en
constitutionnalisant le droit à l'IVG
notre pays ferait preuve et œuvre de
pionniers dans la matière
ne sous-estimons pas la puissante portée
symbolique d'un tel acte vis-à-vis de
l'Occident
fidèle à sa vocation universaliste il
enverrait un message fort au pays où le
droit à l'avortement est bafoué ou
inexistant la France défend
virogoureusement sur la scène
internationale les droits des femmes
alors allons plus loin je tiens à saluer
le sénateur bas qui dans un esprit
constructif propose de réécrire
l'article unique dans le prolongement de
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel bien que son amendement
prévoit que la loi détermine les
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce la
liberté de la femme de mettre fin à sa
grossesse il ne consacre pas pour autant
le droit l'IVG comme un droit autonome
pour aller plus loin mes chers collègues
j'ai donc déposé un sous amendement dont
l'adoption constitue aurait selon moi
une avancée significative en termes de
rédaction notamment en faisant
apparaître les notions d'effectivité et
de libre accès à ce droit
rien ne s'oppose au rehaussement du
niveau de protection du droit à l'IVG la
Constitution par référence au préalable
de 1789 et de 1946 ainsi qu'aux articles
premiers et 66-1 reconnaît déjà une
série de droits et de liberté
fondamentaux
contrairement à ce que vous affirmez
madame la rapporteur inscrire dans notre
loi fondamentale un droit garantit
depuis près de 50 ans ne semble pas
constituer je vous cite un changement de
nature de la Constitution d'hommageable
nous sommes nombreux dans cette émission
à considérer que la
constitutionnalisation du droit à l'IVG
serait parfaitement compatible avec
notre tradition juridique c'est pourquoi
une larve je majorité du groupe RDPI
soutiendra ce texte au nom du droit des
femmes au nom de leur droit à disposer
de leur corps et tout simplement au nom
de leur liberté
merci
la parole est maintenant madame
Marie-Pierre delagontrie pour le groupe
socialiste pour 6 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux madame la rapporteur mes
chers collègues
n'oubliez jamais
il suffira d'une crise politique
économique religieuse pour que les
droits des femmes nos droits soient
remis en question votre vie durant vous
devrez rester vigilante voilà ce que
déclarait Simone de Beauvoir il y a un
demi-siècle
rappelons-nous le long chemin la lutte a
prépa violente que les femmes ont mené
pour obtenir par la première loi veille
du 17 janvier 75 la dépénalisation de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
n'oublions pas toutes ces femmes
criminalisées pour avoir avorté ou
pouvoir pour avoir aidé d'autres à le
faire n'oublions pas toutes celles qui
sont mortes fautes d'avoir eu accès à
des conditions dignes pour pratiquer un
avortement
la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG dont
nous parlons aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans
cette longue histoire de la lutte des
femmes pour leurs droits parce que ça a
été rappelé notre Constitution et la
règle la plus élevée de l'ordre
juridique elle organise notre vie
institutionnelle mais elle indique aussi
nos valeurs nos principes qui fondent
notre communauté elle traduit notre
contrat social le Comité des droits
économiques socio-éculturels des Nations
Unies a écrit que l'égalité de genre
impose de tenir compte des besoins de
santé des femmes qui diffèrent de ceux
des hommes si ce principe avait été
connu des rédacteurs du Préambule de la
Constitution de 46 son article 3 qui
garantit aux femmes des droits égaux à
ceux des hommes auraient consacré la
liberté reproductive spécifique des
femmes
cette liberté reproductive des femmes et
la condition de l'égalité entre les
sexes et doit figurer au sein du texte
qui fonde notre communauté en tant que
condition pour cette égalité ce serait
en France notre fierté et notre honneur
d'être le premier pays au monde inscrire
dans la Constitution le droit des femmes
à disposer de leur corps
ce combat il est mené par la gauche
depuis longtemps il est aujourd'hui
partagé par plus de 80% des Français qui
sont favorables toutes conviction
politique confondue toute conviction
religieuse confondue pourtant certains
pensent qu'il serait inutile de protéger
le droit d'IVG au motif que la
législation actuelle le protégerait
suffisamment cela a été dit tout à
l'heure par le garde des sceaux ne
sera-t-il pas à leur trop tard pour
légiférer si des forces rétrogrades
prennent le pouvoir et décide de
s'attaquer à ce droit
n'avez-vous pas vu les manifestations
hostiles au droit à l'avortement qui se
sont tenus au cours des derniers mois
notamment dans les rues de Paris il y a
quelques jours rassemblant plusieurs
milliers de personnes d'autres affirment
que le droit à l'IVG serait déjà garanti
constitutionnellement au titre des
libertés fondamentales cela résultent
selon nous d'une incompréhension si le
Conseil constitutionnel n'a pas conclu à
une inconstitutionnalité depuis sa
décision initiale sur la loi veille de
75 puis pour chacune de ces
modifications législatives il n'a
cependant jamais formellement reconnu
l'IVG comme un droit fondamental ces
lois à l'époque ont été validées aux
motifs qu'elle respectait un équilibre
entre d'une part la sauvegarde de la
dignité de la personne humaine contre
toute forme de dégradation et d'autre
part la liberté de la femme qui découle
de l'article 2 de la Déclaration de 1789
mais sans conférer pour autant une
protection autonome au droit à l'IVG et
pour cela que nous nous battons pour
cette constitutionnalisation qui
procurerait évidemment une protection
beaucoup plus forte à ce droit certains
avancent que cela ne résoutrait
cependant pas l'effectivité de son accès
sur l'ensemble du territoire c'est
pourquoi notre texte initial le prévoir
mais pourquoi vous poser
constitutionnalisation d'IVG et la
question de son accès ne peut-on à la
fois améliorer l'accès à l'IVG sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire et donner
une protection supplémentaire à ce droit
en le constitutionnalisant d'autres
qualifient d'inutiles cette
constitutionnalisation au motif qui
n'existerait aucun aucun risque de
remise en cause dans notre pays et
pourtant nous le voyons ce mouvement
nous le voyons en Europe nous le voyons
aux États-Unis et dire cela ces pensées
que la France notre pays serait une
sorte d'Ilo protecteur et protégé dans
une Europe et un monde qui vacille sur
l'ensemble de ses droits
d'autres sur ce même raisonnement aurait
dû s'opposer à la constitutionnalisation
de l'abolition de la peine de mort
puisque vous le savez les engagements
internationaux de la France permettait
de toute façon ce retour en arrière
impossible un mot enfin de la
proposition de notre collègue Philippe
Bas qui s'engage dans cette
constitutionnalisation avec une
rédaction différente qui nous a
détailler précédemment
elle présente selon nous de faiblesses
la première évidente elle n'est pas
conforme au dispositif retenu par
l'Assemblée nationale et donc ne permet
pas à ce stade de votre conforme mais
plus encore
elle choisit d'utiliser le terme de
liberté et non pas le terme de droit or
je le dis au président bail je le dis à
vous tous l'IVG n'est pas seulement une
liberté pour nous c'est un droit mais
cette rédaction proposée à la vertu de
s'engager sur le chemin de la
constitutionnalisation et au fond
rappelons-nous que la première loi
veille n'a pu être adoptée que grâce à
un travail transpartisan et à la
participation des groupes parlementaires
de la gauche qui avait accepté de large
concession alors prenons cette démarche
comme un appel au consensus et à la
construction transpartisane lancée par
Philippe Bas notre groupe la soutiendra
comme étant positive même si elle est
imparfaite et puis monsieur le ministre
je reprendrai à mon compte les propos de
Philippe Bas vous avez fait état d'une
analyse très fournie très intéressante
mais nous avons envie de vous voir
concrétiser cette analyse dans une
rédaction qui serait celle du
gouvernement
nous donne rendez-vous pour cela ce soir
je le dis de manière solennelle le Sénat
a rendez-vous avec son histoire très
bien avec l'histoire du droit des femmes
elle l'attend et ne les désever
la parole et maintenant
à Madame Laurence Cohen pour le groupe
CRCE pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le garder
sous mes chers collègues Gisèle Halimi
affirmait déjà en 1973 il y a dans le
droit d'avortement de la femme une
revendication élémentaire physique de
liberté plusieurs entre vous on dit mes
chers collègues que ce droit existe
qu'il est reconnu depuis la loi veille
du 17 janvier 1975 suite ou mobilisation
des femmes d'associations féministes de
syndicalistes et de partis politiques
progressistes alors pourquoi vouloir le
faire entrer dans la Constitution il est
indéniable qu'en 2023 l'avortement
continue de rencontrer une opposition
certaine que nous vivons ici même dans
cette hémicycle mes chers collègues
quand il s'agit de faire progresser les
droits des femmes il est toujours des
voix pour exiger de les encadrer voire
de les limiter surtout concernant la
liberté d'avoir ou non un enfant c'est
une situation que l'on retrouve en
France en Europe et dans le monde en
plus de ces blocages idéologiques j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de développer ici
même les embûches matériels qui
entravent le droit à l'avortement dans
notre pays fermeture des CIVG manque de
personnel pratiquant l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse tes deux a
double clauses de conscience les femmes
les plus touchées évidemment les femmes
précaires qui n'ont pas la possibilité
d'aller à l'étranger et les ainsi passer
le délai légal c'est une petite musique
qu'on connaît bien qui présente quelques
similitudes avec les années 70 j'espère
donc que le Sénat va se saisir cette
fois-ci de cette PPL pour consolider le
droit l'IVG si fièrement à qui le
constitutionnalisé est une opportunité
qu'il faut saisir car si le Conseil
constitutionnel a toujours jugé les lois
relatives à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse conforme à la Constitution il
n'a pour autant jamais consacré ce droit
sous la forme d'un droit fondamental
ainsi ne bénéficie que d'une protection
législative et non constitutionnelle
aujourd'hui une loi qui porterait
atteinte au droit à l'IVG ne serait pas
censuré mes chers collègues la volonté
de constitutionnaliser le droit à
l'avortement n'est pas nouvelle et ne
date pas de la décision de la Cour
suprême des États-Unis du 24 juin 2022
cela fait 11 ans depuis 2012 que le
Parti communiste porte cette idée et le
groupe avait déposé une proposition de
loi en ce sens dès 2017 nous le répétons
comme nous l'avions soutenu récemment
lors de l'examen de la proposition de
loi constitutionnelle déposée par notre
collègue Mélanie Vogel et dont nous
avions été consignataires il est grand
temps de conférer à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse le statut de
droit fondamental et de l'inscrire dans
la Constitution afin de s'assurer que
l'accès à l'IVG ne puisse être affaibli
voire supprimer par des dispositions
législatives pour y parvenir il faut
voter la loi conforme à celle qui a été
adoptée à l'Assemblée nationale ce qui
au vu du rapport de force semble quelque
peu incertains néanmoins depuis octobre
et le rejet ici d'une première PPL
constitutionnelle les débats dans la
société ont peut-être contribué à faire
évoluer certaines positions c'est ainsi
que notre collègue Philippe basse
souhaite faire bouger les lignes avec un
amendement situé à l'article 34 de la
Constitution comme nous le défendions au
groupe CRCE la rédaction la loi on
termine les conditions dans lesquelles
s'exerce la liberté de la femme de
mettre fin à sa grossesse nous pose
question et nous inquiète sur la
latitude possible et c'est au
législateur de revenir sur certaines
avancées notamment substituant le mot
liberté au mot droit cela étant nous
sommes conscients que c'est amendement
s'il est adopté représente une ouverture
pour permettre à la PPL
constitutionnelle de poursuivre son
parcours législatif notre groupe ne fera
donc rien pour bloquer un tant soit peu
cette proposition de loi en souhaitant
que si l'amendement était voté
majoritairement il pourrait être
rédigé de manière différente reprenant
le mot droit car pour nous c'est
extrêmement important mes chers
collègues comme nous y invite les
associations féministes dont certaines
sont ici présentes et que je salue
soyons le premier pays qui garantisse le
3 à l'interruption volontaire dans la
Constitution et je vais faire mienne
l'appel d'oser le féminisme en octobre
dernier nous appelons la France à être
pionnière dans la protection du droit
l'avortement en devenant le premier pays
à constitutionnaliser ce droit
fondamental donnant ainsi un message
d'espoir pour les fans de ce monde qui
se battent pour leurs droits pour le
respect de leur corps et de leur santé
c'est avec force et toute simplement que
je souhaiterais affirmer devant vous ma
position personnelle sur la PPLC dont
nous battons ce soir ce droit à l'IVG
inscrit dans la loi grâce à la force de
l'engagement d'une femme Simone Veil en
1975 je voterai cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle comme j'ai voté en
faveur du texte de notre collègue
Mélanie Vogel à l'automne dernier
j'entends les contestations de mes
collègues qui dénoncent l'inscription
dans la Constitution d'un droit qui ne
serait pas menacé aujourd'hui qui peut
le certifier pas moi j'entends les
opposants à l'IVG qui profitent de ce
débat pour s'opposer à ce droit voir qui
nous intimide ou qui nous menace
parce que l'IVG doit demeurer un droit
fondamental pour les femmes
inscrivons-le dans la Constitution je
voterai ce texte tout en étant
consciente qu'il ne constitue pas une
fin en soi le vote aujourd'hui est une
étape ainsi n’envoyer à toutes les
femmes un signe envoyé au gouvernement
n'oublions cependant pas que graver
l'IVG dans notre Constitution n'aura de
légitimité que si son accès demeure
garanti partout sur notre territoire
pour toutes les femmes nous pouvons nous
accorder je crois sur cela actuellement
il ne l'est toujours pas ce vote nous
oblige à y remédier au plus vite c'est
un impératif de santé publique face à un
délit de non d'insistance à femmes en
danger au delà des rédactions proposées
la question qui nous est posée ce soir
chers collègues elle est simple
souhaitons-nous consolider ce droit à
l'IVG ma réponse est oui je vous
remercie
merci
la parole la parole est maintenant
madame elsachalke
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la question qui nous est posée
par ce texte et de savoir si nous
voulons apporter une garantie
constitutionnelle au droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse à
titre personnel je le souhaite et je
voterai aujourd'hui comme en octobre
dernier pour la constitutionnalisation
de cette liberté fondamentale pour les
femmes pourquoi parce que la
Constitution est notre texte à valeur
suprême elle est le socle commun des
valeurs et des libertés fondamentales de
notre société celle auxquelles nous ne
devons pas déroger inscrire l'IVG dans
la Constitution c'est inscrire ce droit
fondamental au sommet de notre
hiérarchie des normes c'est sacralisé un
droit qui a fait l'objet de très
nombreux combats pour faire partie de
notre patrimoine juridique fondamental
alors où les droits des femmes en
général et le droit à l'avortement
particulier peuvent faire l'objet de
recul dans des pays pas si lointains et
même si la situation américaine pas
comparable à la nôtre j'ai la conviction
que conférer la plus haute protection à
ce droit et pertinent les droits des
femmes nécessitent notre constante
vigilance notre mobilisation et notre
action de chaque instant l'absence
actuelle de remise en cause dans notre
pays de l'IVG ne saurai nous exonérer de
tout faire pour protéger et garantir des
aujourd'hui ce droit auquel nous sommes
tous attachés
[Musique]
la parole est maintenant madame Muriel
jourdat
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur président la condition
des lois madame attends mes chers
collègues j'avoue que j'ai quelques
difficultés à reconnaître le Sénat dans
ces débats qui nous anime et qui nous
animent peut-être longtemps puisqu'il
n'y a pas eu moins de 6 PPL qui ont été
déposés sur ce sujet j'ai des
difficultés à le reconnaître parce que
nous nous vendons souvent d'une certaine
sagesse sénatoriale et je ne la
reconnais pas dans ce débat car la
réalité est que nous réagissons comme de
vulgaire tabloïdes à un événement qui ne
nous concerne pas qui ne nous regarde
pas qui est une décision de la Cour
suprême des États-Unis qui n'a aucun
impact sur la France de la même façon de
notre décision n'aura aucun impact sur
les États-Unis et cela me paraît assez
surprenant j'avoue que je suis aussi
surprise parce que nous avons l'habitude
de faire preuve d'une certaine
objectivité or ici j'entends que nous
débattons de l'IVG comme si c'était le
sujet de ce soir et comme si
véritablement une menace
sur cette liberté des femmes en France
vous savez que ça n'est pas le cas vous
savez que nous ne discutons pas de l'IVG
et vous savez aussi que même si l'on
brandit assez facilement la menace de
l'extrême droite qui pourrait nous
priver de cette liberté à l'Assemblée
nationale l'extrême droite a
majoritairement voté pour la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG donc là
encore nous manquons d'objectivité nous
avons aussi généralement une certaine
rigueur juridique lorsque nous parlons
et aujourd'hui j'entends parler de la
Constitution comme si c'était un
fourre-tout dans lequel nous pouvions
inscrire tout ce qui nous tenait à cœur
et que protégeait comme un coffre-fort
là aussi vous savez que c'est faux vous
savez que là la Constitution et bien
c'est l'ensemble des règles qui
régissent nos institutions qu'elle n'est
pas intangible puisque nous l'avons
modifié 24 fois depuis 1958 et que
probablement cette liberté n'a pas grand
chose à y faire même si le Conseil
constitutionnel indiqué qu'elle
découlait d'une liberté déjà prévue dans
la Constitution qui est la liberté des
femmes et enfin j'ai l'habitude aussi me
semble d'un certain respect ici or
j'entends que certains auraient des
positions dignes et d'autres dans
n'aurait pas nous avons toujours des
positions d'inities elles sont diverses
mais elles doivent pour être acceptées
et pour ma part je ne voterai pas ce
texte
20 secondes je dis rien alors merci
c'est moi qui gère le temps
merci Madame Jordan
la parole
la parole est à la présidente Rossignol
et à elle seule monsieur le Président je
m'étais inscrite parce qu'évidemment
c'est un débat sur lequel j'ai des
éléments à partager avec le Sénat et
puis je vois les inscrits
s'afficher de plus en plus nombreux au
fur et à mesure du débat je vois même
des collègues qui ont ce qu'ils ont
exprimés dans la discussion générale
s'inscrire de nouveau sur l'article et
je sais qu'après cet article il y a
l'amendement de fit du quester-bas qui
va donner lieu aussi à des prises de
parole et puis je sais qu'à 20h45 tout
s'arrête donc je ne voudrais pas que le
Sénat ayant déjà il y a quelques temps
au mois d'octobre était remarqué pour
son vote hostile à la Constitution soit
aujourd'hui remarquer pour une manœuvre
de procédure qui consisterait à faire
durer le débat et à ce que nous ne
puissions pas voter aujourd'hui ni
l'amendement de Philippe Bani le texte
voilà
comme l'a dit nous avons déjà ce n'est
pas la première fois que nous discutons
ni de l'IVG ni de la
constitutionnalisation donc comme l'a
dit le président karouchi Simon et moi
seul qui parle et je ne passe mon tour
de parole au profit d'un vote dans les
temps oui monsieur le Président qui
s'exprimera à titre personnel
contrairement à tout à l'heure où je
prenais de la parole au nom du groupe
d'union centriste il y a plusieurs
débats il y a le débat de l'influence
internationale sur nos débats intérieurs
il y a la question de l'opportunité de
savoir s'il faut mettre cette référence
à l'IVG dans la Constitution mais il y a
un débat qui est un débat juridique et
dans le rappel au règlement je rappelais
qu'on en est à quatre rédactions
il y a la rédaction de Madame Vogel il y
a la rédaction initiale de Madame panot
il y a
il y a la rédaction de l'Assemblée
nationale et on aura à débattre tout à
l'heure de la de la rédaction proposée
par Philippe Bas le tout dans des délais
contraints avec une proposition de loi
un deuxième véhicule légitime et d'une
proposition de loi donc pas des jus
d'impact pas de passage au Conseil
d'État et pas de débat en droit et en
plus avec une procédure dont on sait
tous qu'elle n'ira pas à son terme
puisque la seule issue c'est le
référendum dans la situation actuelle du
pays avec quatre rédactions et une issue
hypothétique et celle du référendum
est-ce que ceux qui sont les défenseurs
de l'IVG imaginent une seconde ce que
représentera un débat sur une question
sociétale de cet ampleur là dans l'état
actuel de la société française je pose
la question comme ça parce qu'en fait il
y a un moment on est on est non
seulement dans cette maison on arrête de
faire du droit
et on parle que de sujets politiques en
disant c'est très bien de mettre ce
sujet dans la Constitution moi j'y suis
je suis hostile à cette inscription mais
si on devait imaginer de le faire
faudrait quand même se poser la question
de la qualité du droit qu'on écrit
on est quand même des législateurs et ce
dont on parle c'est la qualité de la
Constitution pour les pour les années
qui viennent une loi ça se fait ça se
défait une constitution ça se ça se
défait pas aussi simplement que ça donc
on est en train de on est en train mes
chers collègues
d'improviser et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il fallait faire ce rappel là à
cet instant merci
merci je demande vraiment à chacun de ce
contenir de se retenir pour le moment le
débat est serein ça ne sert strictement
à rien de l'envenimer il reste 35
minutes on va le faire calmement
la parole est au président retaillod
merci monsieur le Président de SP
préalable bien entendu il n'y a pas d'un
côté le camp de la dignité et le camp de
l'indignité nos démocraties s'abîmes
quand on réduit le débat public à une
polarisation à un échange de
condamnation et d'accusation on doit
pouvoir en débattre quelle que soit les
opinions des uns ou des autres moi je
pense que nous sommes le Sénat et je
pense que le Sénat ne doit pas
fonctionner sous la pression de tel ou
telle opinion publique mais que nous
devons légiférer de façon rationnelle et
raisonnable cette PPLC est-elle
rationnelle je ne le crois pas parce que
le droit l'IVG et je remercie Agnès
canailler notre rapporteur qu'il a très
bien démontré n'est pas menacé dans son
existence même en France par aucune
formation politique et le Conseil
constitutionnel en quelque sorte
constitutionnalisée ce droit à l'IVG
puisque que il a indiqué dans un certain
nombre de ses décisions qu'il
constituait un élément de la liberté
fondamentale de la femme
cette PPL c est elle aussi raisonnable
est-ce raisonnable chers collègues
d'importer dans notre pays déjà si
fracturé les débats qui fractuent la
société américaine est-il raisonnable
aussi de vouloir sur un tel sujet
monsieur le ministre garde des sceaux
est-il raisonnable de vouloir un
référendum parce que vous savez
pertinemment que pour que cela aboutisse
il faudra passer par le référendum enfin
est-il raisonnable de vouloir
constitutionnaliser à tout va Dominique
delaj la très bien dit demain si on a
par exemple le droit au suicide assisté
il y a la paix à ma pour toutes pourquoi
donc ces droits serait-il de porter
inférieur à l'IVG pourquoi donc demain
ne devrions-nous pas aussi les
constitutionnaliser je pense que la
Constitution la Constitution française
de la 5ème république elle n'est pas
faite pour adresser des messages
symboliques au monde entier
merci
la parole
monsieur ravier merci monsieur le
Président je l'ai dit répéter j'ai même
organisé un coloc ici même au Sénat pour
le démontrer et j'en ai été d'ailleurs
très heureux la constitutionnalisation
du droit l'IVG est inutile et dangereuse
elle est inutile car il n'y a pas de
sujet chez nous en France le droit à
l'IVG n'est pas à menacé alors pourquoi
cette proposition pourquoi cette
obsession de la gauche la principale
raison la frustration la frustration
politique la loi de dépénalisation de
1900 la loi de 1975
tout de suite donnez-moi la parole de
tout la séance est suspendue
huissier évacuer la tribune évacuer la
tribune si je
si jeune et
déjà idéologiquement contaminé
naturellement et comme il se doit nous
saurons qui a invité ces personnes
c'est la règle c'est la règle
je vous rappelle que l'article 91 du
Règlement du Sénat prévoit que le public
admis dans les tribunes se tient assis
découvert et en silence et que toute
personne donnant des marques
d'approbation ou d'improbation est exclu
sur le champ
monsieur
je reprends donc mon propos la
principale raison la frustration la
frustration politique la loi de
dépénalisation 1960 de 1975 a été pensé
rédigé et proposé par le ministre de
droite Simon zaï soutenu par une
majorité un gouvernement et un président
de la République de droite alors depuis
48 ans la gauche ne l'a toujours pas
digéré elle rumine elle enrage d'abord
été dépossédé de ce qui lui revenait
idéologiquement de droit au même titre
que l'abolition de la peine de mort elle
a saisi une actualité tronquée venue
d'outre Atlantique pour un grand coup
d'agit propre comme la scie justement
qualifiée l'ancien secrétaire général du
Conseil constitutionnel tenter d'imposer
son hold-up politique comptant sur la
faiblesse de ses opposants qui s'est
exprimée à l'Assemblée nationale elle
souhaite ainsi récupérer son patrimoine
idéologique mais je vous mets en garde
mes chers collègues de droite nous
sommes en face d'une gauche française
minée par son fanatisme qui la poussera
à exiger toujours plus de vous après la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG ce sera
la constitutionnalisation de la fin de
vie et de l'euthanasie si vous posez un
genou à terre mes chers collègues elle
exigera que vous posiez le second après
que vous ayez peu de poser le second
exigera que vous mettiez à plat ventre
si vous vous mettez à plat ventre elle
vous fera ramper ce sont des fanatiques
il n'en n'ont jamais assez alors je vous
invite mes chers collègues de droite à
rester debout fort et fier de votre vote
j'en appelle à votre courage et à votre
esprit de résistance ne lâchez rien ne
lâchez rien pardon lapsus lapsus
révélateur votre vote notre vote nous
engage à tous ne laissez pas allez
c'est terminé monsieur ravier vous
n'avez plus la parole mais qu'est-ce que
c'est ça je croyais qu'on pouvait courir
voyez qu'on pouvait couper la parole
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce cirque ah bah
oui c'est trop tard eh ben oui mais
c'est trop tard merci
merci Monsieur ravier merci Monsieur
ravier la parole est à Monsieur bonne
Carrère et si chacun pouvait retrouver
son calme en attendant que l'on sache
les suites de l'incident
il a pas de micro
c'est bon c'est bon monsieur oui
monsieur le Président je mets chers
collègues je vous proposerai que nous
oublions les incidents auxquels nous
venons d'assister
il est bien évident qu'il desservent la
cause qu'il voudrait défendre et je suis
quand même trop respectueux même si je
ne partage pas les positions qui ont été
présentées par les soutiens de cette
proposition de loi je suis trop
respectueux de l'importance que vous a
que vous apportez à ce sujet pour que
nous ayons une appréciation par rapport
à ce type d'incidence je vous propose
vraiment que nous les oublions trois
réserves pour justifier pour la majorité
de notre groupe un vote négatif le
premier vous le comprenez bien concerne
notre Constitution notre Constitution
c'est le socle c'est ce qui nous a
permis de faire face à des moments
difficiles c'est un élément de stabilité
et une constitution c'est d'abord le
fonctionnement de nos institutions si
nous avons une constitution qui évolue
vers un recueil de dispositions
sociétales et je crois que ce soir nous
ouvririons une porte qui me un petit peu
dit un petit peu difficile je crois que
nous nous rendrions pas service à notre
Constitution et au fonctionnement de
notre système
deuxièmement vous dire que
la société française est déjà assez
troublée l'idée d'un référendum alors
que d'autres sujets de référendum fusent
dans la société française je vous trouve
vraiment bien joueur d'envisager je peux
jouer à entre guillemets bien entendu
d'envisager de passer par la voix du
référendum en cette matière troisième et
dernière élément
ont été évoqués bien sûr le fait que les
dispositions de la Cour suprême
américaine ne nous concerne ni de près
ni loin mais je voulais simplement
attirer votre attention sur le fait que
si vous partez de l'idée que demain
notre système parlementaire pourrait
être complètement renversé et que notre
système constitutionnel pourrait
conduire le Conseil constitutionnel à
revenir sur Charger espérance de 2001
c'est vraiment alors là on a un problème
majeur dans notre société pour arriver à
un tel défaut de confiance sur notre
Parlement et sur le Conseil
constitutionnel
madame Gatel j'imagine je pense que
c'est la dernière oratrice mais bon
merci merci
de vos je vous remercie
à l'apaisement le sujet dont nous
parlons est un sujet
éminemment important il s'agissait dans
un premier temps de permettre
l'effectivité d'un droit et nous avons
fait un pas de côté sur une autre
réponse à une question qui est celle de
la capacité de notre pays à faire
respecter un droit qui est celui du
droit à l'IVG qui a été porté par une
femme qui appartient à la même famille
politique que nous les centrices et que
je regrette qu'ici nous oublions parfois
que nous sommes un lieu de raison un
lieu de fabrique de la loi un lieu
d'opinion et un lieu de liberté et que
je voudrais dire que je soutiens
parfaitement les propos qui ont été
tenus par leur rapporteur elle a un
discours extrêmement rigoureux et
factuel deuxièmement je voudrais dire
que je trouve fort inconvenant que l'on
n'ose évoquer ici peut-être pas
clairement mais par allusion
sous-entendus qu'il y aurait le camp des
bien-pensants et celui des conservateurs
qui seraient peut-être même des
mécréants et enfin je refuse enfin avec
tout le respect que j'ai pour nos
collègues socialistes et je sais
l'importance qu'ils accordent à ça je
refuse qu'à la sortie de cette PPL si
elle n'était pas votée parce que le
temps n'aurait pas été respecté on
incombe la responsabilité à ceux qui ont
aussi le droit de s'exprimer et qu'il
appartient à chacun quand on a une niche
de choisir ses sujets et le temps qui
est donné je vous remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
et bien nous allons passer à
l'amendement de Monsieur Philippe Bas
qui a la parole
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues je vous propose d'effacer
totalement la proposition qui nous vient
de l'Assemblée nationale pour écrire que
la loi détermine les conditions dans
lesquelles s'exerce la liberté de la
femme de maître fin à sa grossesse c'est
une formule qu'on retrouve fréquemment
dans l'énoncé des libertés
constitutionnelles elle permet de
préserver l'équilibre de la loi veille
je me réjouis que sur tous les bancs on
est manifesté ainsi fort attachement à
la loi veille elle permet aussi au
législateur de ne pas abdiquer ses
droits en faveur du pouvoir constituant
car la loi veille pourra continuer à
évoluer vous savez que si elle avait été
cristallisée dans la Constitution aucune
évolution n'aurait été possible y
compris celle des dernières années et
donc là le sujet reste un sujet
législatif mais s'il y avait un
changement de la juris du Conseil
constitutionnel la liberté de la femme
enceinte
de mettre fin à sa grossesse serait
préservée je ne crois à aucun moment à
une telle évolution jurisprudentielle
c'est pour ça que je reconnais bien
volontiers que cette garantie réelle est
aussi virtuelle mais après tout pour le
cas où il y aurait une telle inflexion
de la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitution je ne vois pas pourquoi
nous nous priverions de l'avantage
d'avoir inscrit dans le marbre de la
Constitution une liberté qui est déjà
reconnue comme une liberté de rang
constitutionnelle par le Conseil
constitutionnel et cela depuis plus de
20 ans une liberté d'ailleurs à laquelle
nous sommes tous profondément attachés
merci je précise tout de suite mais vous
l'avez vu sur le tableau qu'il n'y a
plus de sous amendement donc il n'y a
que l'amendement de Philippe Bas avide
la commission sur cet amendement madame
la rapporteur oui merci monsieur le
Président alors effectivement cette
amendement
modifie entièrement et considérablement
la proposition de loi mais nous
émettrons et la Commission a émis à un
avis défavorable en effet cet amendement
est contraire à la position qui a été
adoptée par le Sénat en octobre dernier
puisque nous restons cohérents nous
pensons que la loi veille garantit
l'avortement en France et que c'est une
garantie forte pour les femmes et qu'il
n'y a pas lieu de constitutionnaliser
alors qu'il n'y a aucune remise en cause
de l'IVG en France aujourd'hui
a supposer que cet amendement comme
l'indique l'auteur ne change rien à
l'existant alors on peut se poser la
question de à quoi sert-il nous sommes
opposés je les ai déjà dit à la
constitutionnalisation pour le symbole
et la commission des lois c'est toujours
opposée à un droit strictement expressif
sur le fond en fait mais l'auteur le
reconnaît cet amendement n'apporte rien
n'ajoute rien au droit positifs puisque
l'article 34 de la Constitution prévoit
déjà que la loi détermine les garanties
fondamentales accordées aux citoyens
pour l'exercice des libertés publiques
et donc intègre évidemment le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
de plus et je le redis et je pense que
il est important que la Constitution de
1958 ne soit pas un catalogue de droit
et de liberté qui en changerait la
nature catalogue de droits et de liberté
parce que évidemment c'est sans fin on
pourrait en ajouter d'autres comme la
liberté de la femme la liberté du voyage
à liberté entreprendre etc etc et
ensuite Simone Veil avait elle-même dit
et je le redis qu'on ne
constitutionnalisait pas pour le symbole
qu'on constitutionnalisait simplement
pour ajouter un droit nouveau ce qui
n'est pas le cas pour cette amendement
ensuite et enfin si vraiment on
considère qu'il est nécessaire de
constitutionnaliser de consacrer la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
notamment ce qui concerne l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse alors chers
collègues il manque une partie du
raisonnement émis par le Conseil
constitutionnel puisque l'amendement ne
fait pas expressément référence à la
nécessaire conciliation avec la
sauvegarde du principe de dignité de la
personne humaine que le Conseil
constitutionnel concilie toujours avec
la liberté pour la femme de mettre fin à
sa grossesse et enfin dernière argument
je réitère que nous sommes dans le cadre
d'une proposition de loi et cette
procédure impose le recours au
référendum et engager un référendum sur
ce sujet n'est absolument pas
responsable c'est pour ça que nous
émettons un avis défavorable
[Applaudissements]
merci avec du gouvernement monsieur le
garde des sceaux
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le Custer Philippe Bas
tout à l'heure vous avez dit que j'avais
les mains dans les poches n'est-ce pas
je dois vous rappeler que non seulement
je n'ai pas les mains dans les poches
mais je n'ai pas non plus la langue dans
la poche et que j'ai exprimé à de
nombreuses reprises le fait que le
gouvernement soutiendrait les
initiatives parlementaires et je trouve
assez singulier d'entendre dans votre
bouche je vous le dis avec beaucoup de
sympathie au fond que vous ayez besoin
d'une impulsion gouvernementale vous qui
souvent être
l'ardent défenseur du du parlementarisme
et de ces initiatives souvent heureuses
pour ne pas dire toujours je suis assez
surpris de ça il y a eu six textes qui
ont été présentés moi j'ai dit la
première ministre a dit non seulement
nous les regardons mais nous les
soutiendrons
bon et d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs et et
d'ailleurs
laisser le travail parlementaire se
terminer
mais j'ai bien compris il y a aussi une
navette
voilà et nul ne l'ignore alors pour le
reste je veux saluer votre votre
proposition qui démontre à l'évidence
presque dire comme toujours votre
volonté de parvenir à une écriture de
compromis n'est-ce pas voilà mais j'ai
un petit doute je l'ai exprimé tout à
l'heure je ne vais pas le redire je
pense que c'est l'état du droit actuel
et donc
regarde cette amendement
qui fait un pas vers le compromis le
Gouvernement émet un avis de sagesse
merci Monsieur le garder sur
un peu calme j'ai déjà plusieurs
demandes de parole d'explication de vote
sur l'amendement alors pour de bon cette
fois-ci levez la main une fois alors
allons-y une non mais moi ça m'est
complètement égal
un jour dans la
et le président buffet
pas de regret et ben on y va la parole
est d'abord à madame la Présidente
rossignol
merci monsieur le Président le débat
aujourd'hui porte sur l'amendement
déposé par le questerba la question du
gouvernement viendra après et je me
concentrerai aujourd'hui sur cette
amendement pour dire qu'en ce qui
concerne mon groupe et elle le diront si
le temps est possible pour tous les
groupes qui avaient soutenus et
participé à la proposition de droite et
posée par Mélanie Vogel au mois
d'octobre nous allons voter l'amendement
de Philippe Bas et je voudrais dire au
collègue qui pense que la Constitution
n'est pas faite pour être un catalogue
que le droit à l'IVG n'est pas n'importe
quelle liberté qu'aujourd'hui si nous en
parlons c'est bien parce que c'est la
liberté des femmes le droit des femmes
systématiquement mise en cause par tous
les gouvernements il libéraux et ceux
qui disent qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de danger pour demain sont bien
optimistes bien optimiste mes chers
collègues écoutez ce que nous dit notre
collègue gravier
c'était la forme et le fond de son
intervention qui d'entre nous peut dire
monsieur ravier ne représente pas un
courant politique à 1,5% dans le temps
de pays monsieur ravier représente un
courant politique dont on sait très bien
qu'il peut un jour gouverner ce pays et
aujourd'hui voter un amendement qui
inscrit dans la Constitution la liberté
la liberté des femmes d'accéder à
l'avortement c'est envoyé un signal à
qui non pas aux jeunes gens qui
manifestaient il y a 10 jours en
demandant au Sénat de ne pas voter la
constitutionnalisation envoyer un signal
à tous les progressistes qui veulent la
constitutionnalisation à ses 80% de
français notre vote il dira qui nous
parlons aux adversaires de l'IVG ou à
ceux qui promouvent les droits des
femmes voilà parce que seul qui vous ont
demandé les seuls qui vous ont demandé
aujourd'hui de ne les sols qui nous
demandent de ne pas voter la
constitutionnalisation les sols qui
manifestent pour ne il y a des
manifestations il nous demande de ne pas
le voter ce sont les adversaires de
l'IVG à eux il faut dire non nous votons
parce que nous défendons le droit des
femmes leur liberté leur liberté aucune
femme ne peut en être privé c'est ce que
dit l'amendement balle de voteront
merci de participer à la série
madame Cohen
mes chers collègues c'est quand même
assez
disons troublant de voir que dès qu'il
s'agit d'aborder
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
il y a un débat qui devient extrêmement
passionné et beaucoup de tumulte
moi je veux simplement dire mes chers
collègues écouter les écouter les
arguments au lieu de vociférer écouter
les arguments pour l'instant je ne les
ai pas avancés vous ne pouvez pas savoir
si vous allez vous inscrire en pour ou
en compte ce que je vais dire je dis
simplement que c'est tout le c'est un
constat c'est un fait alors sur
l'amendement de Monsieur bah je l'ai dit
dans mon propos liminaire j'y vois un
signe positif parce que ça pourrait
permettre au Sénat rassemblés de dire
oui il y a nécessité de
constitutionnaliser ce droit et je
trouve que même en étant mon groupe
l'ensemble de mon groupe et moi-même
plutôt en désaccord qu'il y ait
seulement le mot liberté parce que pour
nous l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse n'est pas seulement une
liberté c'est un droit et un droit
charmant acquis et nous aurions souhaité
qu'il y ait ces deux termes après je
vous appelle à la réflexion pourquoi
quand il s'agit de ce droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
il est toujours indispensable de faire
des compromis et de l'encadrer voire de
dire ce que j'ai entendu là encore c'est
un fait on ne peut pas tout mettre
n'importe quoi dans la Constitution
demandez demandez entendez ce que nous
demandons c'est-à-dire que ce droit soit
considéré comme un droit fondamental
parce que c'est un droit fondamental
pour les femmes qui sont des êtres
majeurs à égalité dans ce pays et dans
le monde de pouvoir décider d'avoir une
grossesse ou pas quand elle le souhaite
pour moi pour l'ensemble de mon groupe
c'est un droit fondamental et je pense
que par rapport à ce qui se passe dans
le pays il y a des collègues d'autres
camps politiques ou d'autres bancs
politiques qui peuvent partager ça donc
je vous je vous encourage à réfléchir et
à voter l'amendement de Monsieur bas
madame Jourda
merci monsieur le Président c'est assez
curieux parce que notre collègue madame
Cohen votre race est amendement tout en
étant en désaccord avec ces termes et
moi je ne le voterai pas tout en pensant
que c'est plutôt une amélioration par
rapport à la rédaction initiale puisque
effectivement
il me paraît plus juridiquement précis
car une droite un droit et une liberté
ça n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
et sans pouvoir disposer du temps
nécessaire pour retracer l'existence de
cette liberté c'est effectivement une
liberté et non pas un droit et on peut
au moins reconnaître ce mérite à
l'amendement de Philippe Bas qui est de
dire exactement ce que sont les choses
pour autant je reprendrai mais
évidemment beaucoup plus rapidement
l'argumentation de madame le rapporteur
cette liberté pour les femmes de pouvoir
recourir à l'avortement elle découle
déjà d'une liberté constitutionnellement
reconnue et nous n'allons pas inscrire
dans la Constitution toute la liberté
qui découle de la Constitution elle-même
sauf à en faire effectivement un code
qui serait tout à fait inutilisable et
qui ne servirait plus à ce à quoi est
destiné la Constitution je le rappelle
et pour finir puisqu'il me reste
quelques secondes je voudrais tout de
même rappeler comme je l'ai fait tout à
l'heure mais manifestement il faut le
rappeler que que nous ne sommes pas ici
entre partisans de l'IVG et opposant à
l'IVG comme je l'entends on peut
parfaitement ne pas voter ce texte et il
y a tout à fait favorable à cette
liberté des femmes de recourir à l'IVG
et évidemment on peut dire que les
droits ne sont jamais acquis les
libertés ne sont jamais acquises c'est
exact mais il faut quand même être
sérieux depuis 1975 les parlementaires
quel que soit leur opinion sur la
question car il y a des parlementaires
qui sont opposés à l'IVG ils en ont
parfaitement droit n'ont jamais déposé
un quel contexte pour revenir sur la loi
veille et toutes les modifications qui
ont été faites et qui sont autonomes
dont 7 ont toujours rendu plus aisés
l'exercice de cette liberté alors
arrêtons de nous faire peur pour des
choses qui n'existent pas aujourd'hui
rien n'est menacé et il ne sert à rien
d'entrer dans la loi fondamentale une
liberté qui n'a rien à y faire c'est la
parole est à Madame billon
merci monsieur le Président alors en
préambule je voudrais dire que tout à
l'heure certains ont voulu opposer des
camps moi je voudrais dire aussi qu'il y
a pas le camp d'un côté des spécialistes
du droit des spécialistes de la
Constitution qui seraient contre la
constitutionnalisation et les autres à
côté qui seraient totalement hors sujet
et qui nous avons nous aussi ceux qui
sont pour la constitutionnalisation et
bien une responsabilité pleine et
entière de l'écriture de la loi donc moi
je remercie notre collègue Philippe Bas
pour cette rédaction de compromis qui
pourrait peut-être nous rassembler pour
avancer sur ce chemin de la
constitutionnalisation du droit à l'IVG
parce que pour moi c'est pas un symbole
pour moi c'est la protection d'un droit
fondamental et je vais bien entendu
voter ce amendement cet amendement de
compromis parce que personne aujourd'hui
ne peut garantir que le droit à l'IVG
n'est pas menacé je peux pas vous dire
qu'il est menacé vous pouvez pas me dire
qu'il n'est pas menacé et donc la
passion d'ailleurs qui a aidée était
déchaînée à un moment dans les débats ce
soir et certains arguments le démontrent
donc je vais voter cet amendement pour
garantir un droit fondamental pour les
femmes dans la Constitution je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur ravier
merci pour votre accueil chaleureux
monsieur le sénateur Philippe Bas je
suis étonné à plusieurs égards par votre
amendement venant d'un gaulliste tout
d'abord vous souhaitez participer à
l'horizontalisation de la Constitution
dans un texte à verte de verticalité
golienne minant l'intérêt général qui
avait présidé à ces rédactions vous
contribuez à découdre notre contrat
social vous appuyez cette manie
dangereuse d'en faire un self service
normatif venant dans d'opposant aux
inutilités constitutionnelles ensuite
vous disiez en juin 2018 que
l'introduction d'une mention à
l'environnement l'article 1 de la
Constitution n'était je vous cite pas
une question de numérotation car ça ne
changeait rien à ce que dit déjà la
Charte de l'environnement ici aussi ce
n'est pas une question de numérotation
et votre rédaction ne change rien à ce
que dit déjà la loi actuellement en
vigueur venant d'un sénateur attaché au
rôle du Parlement vous choisissez de
nous déposséder un peu plus de notre
pouvoir de décision au profit d'un juge
constitutionnel venant d'un proche
collaborateur de Simone Veil vous
prétendait soutenir l'esprit de sa loi
était une dépénalisation en l'inscrivant
sur la clé de voûte de notre édifice
normatif vous assumez de l'ériger en
panacée sociétale enfin venant d'un élu
de droite je crois vous validez
l'initiative d'agide propre et encore vu
aujourd'hui dans les tribunes vous
validez l'initiative d'agide propre de
l'extrême gauche qui ne cherche qu'à
procéder sur le dos de la Constitution
qu'à une OPA une opération politique sur
l'avortement chers collègues à votre
tour ne tombez pas dans ce piège
électoral soyez ferme sur vos
convictions sinon je l'ai déjà dit
jusqu'où irons-nous j'espère que vos
votes d'automne ne se seront pas envolés
avec l'action du vent mauvais venant de
la gauche et que vous serez amené à la
lumière des quelques paradoxes que je
viens de soulever à rejeter cet
amendement prélude au rejet du texte
merci monsieur le Président c'est la
parole est au président buffet
monsieur le Président moi je vais
simplement faire juste un petit point
juridique
l'article 37 de la Constitution dans
lequel l'amendement de notre collègue
est présenté
qui a 34 pardon
peut faire durer madame Rossignol avec
beaucoup de plaisir
j'ai la possibilité de le faire c'est
pas mon objectif mais je peux le faire
si vous le souhaitez
il y a aucune difficulté
d'ailleurs je vais discuter un peu
quelques collègues en attendant
je disais donc que l'article 34 37
pardon
à une vocation première
qui est de répartir
à la fois le pouvoir de l'exécutif et le
pouvoir législatif c'est sa seule
vocation
il est le résultat du fait que sur la
Quatrième République
l'effet les pouvoirs n'étaient pas clair
l'instabilité était présente et que le
constituant de 58 a voulu clarifier les
choses
ce qui fait que l'inscription de cet
amendement à cet endroit là ne changera
rien son effet juridique il n'y aura pas
en tous les cas l'effet juridique que
vous souhaitez puisque c'est la chose
prudence du Conseil constitutionnel qui
continuera de s'appliquer c'est
simplement ce que je voulais dire pour
que chacun ait bien conscience des
enjeux
voilà merci
monsieur Delhaize
merci monsieur le Président j'avoue que
je suis un peu resté sur ma faim si je
fais un film exprimer sur la position du
garde des sceaux
qui représente je crois ici le
gouvernement n'aurait été content de
savoir ce que comptait faire le
gouvernement si
l'amendement de monsieur va était adopté
ou si d'ailleurs il n'était pas adopté
et que le texte initial était adopté
parce que nous avons été un certain
nombre à vous questionner sur les
intentions et le calendrier si c'était
opportun d'organiser un référendum dans
le contexte actuel et vous nous avez pas
répondu je le regrette parce que ça
mériterait un exercice ment tout ça en
tous les cas certains nombre de
collègues serait content de savoir ce
que compte faire le gouvernement avec
cette affaire au-delà de nous dire que
vous soutenez on aimerait savoir comment
vous allez soutenir puis la deuxième
observation que je voulais faire c'est
que
malgré tout le respect que je porte à
notre collègue Philippe Bas qui est un
fin juriste j'avoue que j'ai du mal à
voir l'apport dans la constitution de la
formule qui consiste à dire la loi
détermine les conditions dans lesquelles
s'exerce la liberté de mettre fin à sa
grossesse c'est déjà le cas donc
qu'est-ce que ça apporte de plus sinon
d'introduire un article supplémentaire
et le terme
non pas dirigé mais de fin de grossesse
donc je pense qu'il faut dire les choses
en vérité la proposition de Philippe ban
ne change rien d'ailleurs il le
reconnaît lui-même donc je ne vois pas
l'intérêt d'aller changer quelque chose
qui ne change rien
[Applaudissements]
à certaines ou à certains je vais
reprendre la parole parce que je suis
extrêmement triste de la nature de
débats qui ont lieu ici on est d'abord
un texte sur la constitution de l'IVG
puis en fait on a un débat de fond sur
l'IVG parce qu'on veut absolument nous
entraîner dans un discours qui consiste
à dire il y a les Gentils qui sont
polivés et puis de l'autre côté il y a
les méchants qui sont contre les végés
ce n'est pas le débat d'aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le débat d'aujourd'hui et je
suis désolé moi je fais partie d'une
génération qui dit merci à Simone Veil
et j'ai pas de le soir se voir d'un camp
quel qu'il soit quel qu'il soit nous
avons tous eu nos combats nous avons
tous eu nos engagements et aujourd'hui
l'IVG personne ne le remet en cause
personne on veut nous emmener vers une
discussion qui n'est pas celle de ce
texte de loi et je suis désolé de dire à
certains des collègues ce n'est pas
digne du Sénat
allez dernière orateur inscrit Monsieur
Hervé à moins que d'autres oui encore et
plus même
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
j'entends les le débat sur
des personnes qui seraient les
spécialistes de la Constitution d'autres
qui ne le sauraient pas moi en règle
générale je doute avant de décider et je
n'ai aucune certitude
et ce débat me depuis le début
d'ailleurs depuis me faire réfléchir et
me fait cheminer ce dont je suis sûr
c'est que la rédaction constitutionnelle
qu'on doit choisir
si c'est le choix du du législateur
constitutionnel souverain ou si c'est
chaud du peuple si demain le président
de la République convoquait un homme
chaque mot doit être pesé au trébuchet
on en est à 4 rédactions il y a même
plus le il y a même plus la référence à
l'IVG explicite dans l'amendement de
Philippe Bas imputé à l'article 34 c'est
vous dire le fait que
certains d'entre nous veulent tellement
qui est une référence à l'interruption
retard de grossesse dans la Constitution
qui sont prêts en accepter n'importe
quelle rédaction
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle ce
4 cette quatrième rédaction qui a été
présentée par une rédaction de compromis
j'aimerais savoir entre qui et qui
bah oui un compromis c'est entre les
personnes qui ont des avis différents
donc si la rédaction du questeur
Philippe Bas et d'une rédaction de
compromis j'aimerais savoir entre qui et
qui on en est à 4 rédactions et je pense
que cette quatrième rédaction qui ne
parle même plus de l'interruption
vendeur de grossesse pose une vraie
difficulté donc je voudrais compte
puisque si la maman de Philippe Bas est
adopté
l'article est à nouveau rédigé et ça
emporte adoption la proposition de loi
si j'ai bien compris ce présent ce
serait peut-être pas mal de le rappeler
avant le vote
un dernier orateur pour de bon le
président Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
trois remarques très rapidement la
première c'est que je veux dire à tous
nos collègues que si l'amendement de
Philippe by était adopté il vaudra
adoption de l'ensemble de la PPL je me
rends compte que tous ne sont pas
informés de cette conséquence juridique
deuxième élément gardez ce à des doutes
j'ai une certitude ça a été dit à
plusieurs reprises la maman de Philippe
Bas est superfétatoire sinon dans cette
hémicie comment aurions pu à plusieurs
reprises débattre de textes de PPL
justement qui avait cette portée sur
l'IVG et enfin je ne vois strictement
aucune raison de modifier le vote que
nous avons déjà émis à l'automne dernier
aucune raison d'un revirement je pense
qu'au politique la constance la
cohérence sont des vertus je pense que
j'ai entendu le mot signal le mot
symbolique je pense que la politique
doit être reliée d'abord au réel et
méfions-nous mes chers collègues parce
que à force de déconnecter la politique
les Français se déconnecteront ensuite
de la politique
merci
je vais mettre au voie l'amendement de
rédaction globale de l'article unique
constituant l'ensemble de la proposition
de loi
en application de l'article 59 du
règlement le scrutin public et de droit
il va être possédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin éclos
ultra
votant 341 exprimé 318 pour 166 contre
152 l'amendement est adopté
[Applaudissements]
le loi est donc adopter
[Musique]